what's like the one fandom that you want  to pass on probably Lord of the Rings I  guess that's a tough one but yeah we're  so smart well Star Wars first obviously  may the force be with you basically any  skill berg or George Lucas anything  indiana jones et Justin Timberlake and  Anna Kendrick were at comic-con for  their new movie trolls in theaters on  November 14 while there we put Justin on  the spot for this selfie he shared from  their panel on Thursday it was so bad  look at that silky tail  singer who brought us this summer anthem  says he has been back in the studio and  has an a-list roster for collaborations  I am I am working on some new music I'm  kind of taking my time with it but this  soundtrack I mean we have you have a  song with Gwen and myself and ariana  grande so this soundtrack has been  taking up a lot of my time right now